celebrations of the summer solstice date
back to some of the earliest known
civilizations Stonehenge was estimated
to have been built around 2500 BCE and
while its purpose is unknown it is
speculated to be an ancient solar
calendar as the entrance faces the
Rising Sun on the day of summer solstice
one of the most extravagant celebrations
can be found in Sweden where Midsummer
Gatherings are celebrated with Decor
dancing food and drinks perhaps such
importance was placed on this time of
year because of Sweden's High latitude
on the globe allowing what is known as
the Midnight Sun where daylight can be
observed even in the middle of the night
the Swedish tradition of celebrating the
longest day of the year is believed to
have started in the 1500s as a pagan
Festival of fertility and light these
celebrations may have coincided with
Vikings and sailors returning home from
their voyages and mingling with the
women for the first time in a while and
it became tradition to erect what is
known as the maypole which young women
were meant to dance around in a circular
motion I'm sure you can figure out the
symbolism there on your own as with any
ancient tradition Laura and folk tales
began to be associated with it in one
Countryside Community known as horga a
song called orgolitan was associated
with the maypole dance this song is
based on a 1785 folk tale about the
devil disguised as a fiddler who
possessed the young to dance and dance
until they collapsed and died basically
the earliest known version of that one
Yaya song
the midsummer celebration the horga the
Maple and the horgolitan are all real
cultural phenomena as you may have
figured out if you're a fan of the
Swedish metal band In Flames who covered
horgolitan in 1994 but the cult scene in
the 2019 movie mid-summer have certain
Traditions that don't reflect the
real-life horga namely human sacrifice
in the movie The Dance has evolved into
sort of a competition to Crown the last
answer standing as the May Queen and in
2019 one traumatized girl finds herself
thrust into the festivities to learn the
entire history of the May Queen which
aspects of Swedish folklore are inspired
from real life and the meaning behind
all the insanity that is mid-summer
stick around to the end of this video
[Music]
welcome to horga history Midsummer was
directed by Ari Astor fresh off the
heels of his 2018 breakout film
hereditary which also dealt with the
world of pagan Cults according to
thrillist Astor decided on horga is the
location for a sophomore movie primarily
because he was inspired by the
horgolitan even though he doesn't
specifically use that song during the
ceremony it's always more fun to tether
it to something tangible Astor explains
but then you know you do run the risk of
the real thing being confused for
whatever you've done and that's why I'm
here to sort it all out to understand
the Horgan cult we've got to take it
back to the strange tradition centered
around the black one
it was here long ago that the black one
allured the youths of horga to the grass
and seduced them into dance once they
began they could not stop and dance
themselves to death now in life holding
Defiance of the black one we dance until
we fall and she who survives last will
be crowned for her stamina this is the
explanation given each year at the
beginning of the May Queen ceremony I
would assume that the black one is not
talking about Josh but rather the Devil
Himself in the traditional Swedish folk
song there are several Clues to suggest
that the Fiddler is demonic when he
pulled out his fiddle the people of
horga got excited and forgot God in the
whole world another verse describes the
narrator noticing that the Fiddler has a
hoof a common trait in many depictions
of the devil the song describes a sudden
premature death for the dancers and
mid-summer begins with the sudden
premature death of the protagonist
sister Terry arder and her parents due
to intentional carbon monoxide poisoning
in her final email to her sister Terry
writes I can't anymore everything's
black mom and Dad are coming too goodbye
and while this reads kind of like a
change to World meme it's interesting
that she describes everything is black
and I wonder if this could be referring
to the black one there's also the fact
that Dany has a dream where black smoke
billows from her mouth before seeing the
image of her family replacing the
deceased cultists at the bottom of the
cliff but I'm getting ahead of myself
the traditions of the Horgan cult were
established long before Terry or Dany
were even born in their society they see
the entire Community as a family and
individuality is not important when a
baby is born it is raised by everyone
it's not just the responsibility of the
parents this is not necessarily the case
today in horga but it is true that for
most of human history we traveled in
tribes and babies were taken care of
communally however the Horgan cult in
Midsummer takes the focus on community
to new extremes everyone works together
and jobs are assigned based on traits
shown in childhood meals are cooked for
the entire cult and consumed as one and
even positive or negative emotions are
supposed to be experienced in a group
setting as a whole unit rather than
burdening them individually even
copulation takes place in a group with
several family members singing the joys
of conception alongside the person
engaging in the ACT interpersonal
relationships are rejected in favor of
group love among everyone they mostly
dress in all white so that no individual
person's style can distract from the
unity of the groom they have special
costumes that they wear for each winter
and summer solstice but because the
entire movie takes place during the
festival it's not known how different
these clothes are from whatever
day-to-day Garb that they wear for the
rest of the year during mid-summer at
least Elders wear genderless dress robes
which are inspired by the hermaphroditic
qualities found in nature for example a
berry tree has both male and female
components and is able to flower and
self-pollinate and drop seeds all on its
own it may be no coincidence that when
Outsiders enter the village they're
given strawberries to snack out since
the cult have used itself as one big
unit and contains both male and female
members the cult sees itself as being
hermaphroditic in a way strawberries can
reproduce both sexually and asexually
and the cult takes a similar approach
they bring in Outsiders to impregnate
their women when they become of age in
order to prevent birth defects caused by
low Gene variation but they also
calculatedly approve one incestuous
birth per generation the result is an
inbred child with physical and mental
deformities through the horga sky as
their Oracle because of his or her
disability the Oracle is considered to
be unclouded by normal cognition it
makes him open for the source the Oracle
paints abstract images onto this holy
book and the elders interpret the
renderings as the basis for their
religion it's not clear if the elders
really believe that they're interpreting
the word of God through these paintings
or if this is a ruse in order to give
the illusion of higher power while
they're the ones actually in control
judging by the paintings themselves I'm
leaning towards the latter despite this
one exception incest is still considered
taboo and the elders must approve any
mates in order to properly preserve
Bloodlines but cousins are apparently
fine for them so kind of weird another
aspect of their lives that has a basis
in nature is their life cycles
themselves every milestone in a
horrigan's life is predetermined and the
rituals performed at each of these
Milestones may be shocking to Outsiders
are you tired of mediocre audio ruining
your movie watching experience then
listen up because I've got a game
changer for you these are raycon earbuds
they're the perfect way to immerse
yourself in your favorite horror films
like never before with raycons you can
hear every bone chilling sound and
scream and Crystal Clear quality just
like the filmmakers intended and here's
the best part raycon started half the
price of other premium audio Brands so
you don't have to choose between quality
and affordability plus with their Sleek
design and comfortable fits you can wear
them all day long whether you're
watching movies working out or just
chilling at home raycon earbuds can
block out background noise with passive
noise isolation keeping you fully
immersed in your audio by holding down
the right button you can toggle between
noise isolation mode and awareness mode
in fact it's easy to control your music
without ever taking out your phone you
can control volume pause track skipping
answer and reject calls or activate the
voice assistant and more and if you're
ready to upgrade your audio game I've
got a special offer for you click the
link in the description or go to buy
raycon.com season's world to get 15 off
your raycon purchase this is a small
purchase with a big impact and you won't
regret it that's by
recon.comworld for 15 off the already
affordable prize get yours today
foreign
of each cult member is broken into
season much like Weezer they decided to
start with spraying you're a child until
you're 18 and that's spring and then at
some point we all were a pilgrimage
which is between 18 and 36 and that's
summer and then from 36 to 54 we're a
working age which is fall and then
finally from 54 to 72 you become a
mentor you may or may not notice that
their lives are broken up in 18-year
increments more specifically each
Milestone is a multiple of nine and the
number nine holds a huge significance to
that much like how the number eight
keeps coming up in Astor's previous film
hereditary the number nine appears over
and over again in mid-summer the
mid-summer festival in the movie is
celebrated over nine days as opposed to
six in real life the events in the film
also take place during the special
anniversary known as the great feast
that only occurs every 90 years it has
been 90 years since our last great feast
and it will be 90 years before our next
in one scene Mark freaks out when he
sees the sun is still out at 9pm finally
there are nine human sacrifices I've
seen it suggested by multiple sources
online primarily signal Horizon that the
number nine is tied closely to Norse
mythology in that lore there are nine
Realms the god Odin hung himself in the
tree of life for nine days Adrian ran
the god and goddess of the sea had nine
daughters the Thunder God Thor took nine
steps after winning his final battle
before collapsing dead it goes on and on
like this I'm not John solo I'm not
gonna list them all the Horgan life
cycle ends at age 72 where during the
midsummer Festival a ritual scene aside
called a testipa is performed at the top
of a cliff because everything they do is
for the benefit of the cult it's
considered an honor to do this because
the elders know that they'll never grow
old enough to wear caring for them
becomes a burden there's some debate as
to whether or not a testipo rituals
really took place in the 1600s in Sweden
or if this was merely a myth but it's
definitely not a part of Midsummer
celebrations today Sweden has Affordable
Health Care speaking of money there's
obviously not any legal tender in horga
because the horgans don't subscribe to
the concept of personal ownership
however I'm guessing there is a pool of
money shared by the entire cult after
all there would need to be some money
for the pilgrimage that each member
embarks on upon turning 18. there is
mention of some trade with people
outside the family how do you support
this place lumbering linen homeopathics
water power plants they must bring in a
lot of money with that considering Pell
goes to NYU where the tuition was 53 000
a year in 2019. or you know maybe he
just got a Pell Grant now if you'll
excuse me I'm gonna go perform a testapa
okay I'm back basically the next order
of business after the level 72s learn
about fall damage is the crowning of the
May Queen the reason you probably
clicked on this video as I mentioned the
last woman left Dancing is the winner
what I may have forgotten to mention is
that they aren't literally dancing until
death you Just Dance until you fall down
but in order to make this possible the
participants drink a special herbal tea
with hallucinogenic properties it makes
them see things and they fall this is
another similarity to the cult and
hereditary who used herbal tea to make
their subjects more receptive to
communication with spirits and demons
it's all there in my king payment video
which you can watch later after you're
done watching this video for once in
your life finish what you started when
only one girl remains everyone
celebrates and she's crowned with an
even more elaborate and colorful flower
crown then placed on a pedestal and
paraded to the dinner table where she
sits at the flower thrown at the head of
the table there she is expected to eat a
full salt Herring hole for good luck
pickled herring is a real traditional
Swedish mid-summer recipe and it is said
to be good luck not just in Sweden but
in many Nordic countries I think the
idea of having to swallow it whole in
front of everyone was probably invented
for the movie and I'll get into why a
little bit later after dinner the May
Queen is taken around on a chariot to
bless the crops and livestock for the
upcoming year the torch is literally and
figuratively passed to her and she says
a blessing over some freshly buried
seeds meats and eggs this is all very
important in relation to the cult's
beliefs because they have accepted the
idea of a circle of life since lives
have just been sacrificed the blessing
to sprout new crops and birth new
livestock is the next step in the cycle
each Midsummer the process is repeated
and a new Queen is named at some point
in the 1900s it became tradition to
photograph the May Queen and display the
photo by a window in the main house
where all of the younger ones up to age
36 sleep there are 30 photos shown in
the year that Danny comes to Sweden
which I have no choice but to believe is
2019 in the same year that the movie
came out because we're given no
indication otherwise but many of these
photos are in black and white or sepia
and they look like they may be older
than 1989. they don't seem to be in any
particular order for example the
previous year's photo is right here so
these may not be all of the photos and
the photo tradition May stretch back
further than 30 years if we're calling
the midsummer shown in the movie 2019
then the previous May Queen would have
been named in 2018. whoa who's that one
that's last year's May Queen
beautiful there's some debate as to who
this is because it's kind of hard to
tell from the photo some believe it's
Oola the woman who opens Christian's
eyes at the end of the movie others have
said that atana the one to pass the
torch to Dany after she becomes the May
Queen there's also a possibility that
she isn't around during the events of
mid-summer for whatever reason at the
end of the day we can't really see your
face and like the list of female leads
in Alfred Hitchcock movies they're
practically all young blonde woman at
the very least we do know that there are
former May Queens still in the cult we
should go now to see this house
what's this it's a special meeting only
for the Queens so that catches us up to
present day or you know 2019 but to
understand the 2019 Queen we've got to
take it back to her birth wait we
already did that transition Danielle
arter may have been born on June 25th
1994. we know her birthday is on her
second day in Sweden and on her first
day in Sweden ingamar greets pal in
Swedish however if we look at the script
this is written in English he says happy
Saint John's St John's day is one of the
days of Midsummer and takes place on
June 24th I don't speak Swedish but if
that line is in the movie then Danny was
born on the 25th her birth year in 1994
is not 100 official we don't know her
exact age but the script introduces her
as a 25 year old let's take that with a
grain of salt because the script goes on
to say that she is a beautiful but
delicate brunette so obviously changes
were made one thing that was not changed
is her last name arder the name is
derived from Latin roots one definition
of ardor refers to passion and fervent
love another more literal definition
refers to Flame fire or heat it's a
perfect name because Danny is a
character who is betrayed by her love
then literally sets him on fire as
mentioned Danny has a sister named Terry
who has a bad case of bipolar disorder
resulting in numerous panic attacks that
are a constant source of stress for
Danny potentially driven to help her ill
sister and Dany attends NYU as a
psychology student disaster would soon
strike the art or family and it would
come under very suspicious circumstances
[Music]
in June 2015 Danny began dating an
anthropology student named Christian
Hughes or should I say Christian here as
Danny pronounces his name the same way
that Pell does with a Swedish accent
I've noticed that the other friends
don't do this this could be one of the
earliest clues that she's eventually
going to join the cult and become one
with the horga does this mean that Pell
was actually The Mastermind who
controlled everything from the very
beginning I don't think so I think
ariaster put in a lot of details for the
audience that aren't meant to be used as
evidence that the cult was behind every
little thing like in hereditary in fact
there's an interview on HuffPost where
Astor is questioned about the theory
that Pell was responsible for the deaths
of dany's parents where he says that
it's totally incorrect Danny and
Christine's relationship issue spout
from the heavy emotional Reliance she
has on him for all you terminally online
little freaks you may know this as
trauma dumping trauma uh dumping if you
will Christian debates breaking up with
her over this but puts those plans on
hold after her trauma suddenly becomes
much more valid on December 18th she
starts receiving especially weird emails
from Terry the first is a link to this
National Geographic video the first 3D
VR video filmed in Space the video talks
about how being on a satellite and
seeing 16 sunrises a day messes up your
internal body clock it's it's strange
your body doesn't know what time it is
there's no natural way to tell whether
it's day or night I think this is meant
to show a parallel between what the
astronauts feel with no concept of day
or night and how Dany Christian Mark and
Josh feel in Sweden when they still see
the Sun out at midnight again I think
this is here for the audience I don't
think Terry somehow knew that Danny
would go to Sweden she sends another
YouTube link the next day this one is
another National Geographic video a
relaxing live stream of the Yellowstone
River yellow is the color that
represents rebirth and the cycle of Life
the flowers that can be seen all over
horga are yellow flowers called Saint
John's Wort this is no mistake the
script specifically calls out the bright
yellow Petals of these flowers Danny
passes through the yellow sun gate into
the village where her relationship with
Christian would end and her life with
her new family would begin her birthday
cake has a yellow candle literally tying
it to birth according to the cult birth
and death are directly connected which
is why we also see the color yellow
connected to death the hose Terry
attached to the exhaust pipe was yellow
and she passed away in a yellow shirt
the parents went to sleep for the final
time on yellow pillowcases Danny's
apartment when she's in mourning is
totally covered in yellow from the
pillows to her blanket and lampshade and
of course the sacrificial Temple that is
burned at the end of the movie is Yellow
Coldplay must be going nuts right now
judging by the dates of all of the
emails and calls it appears to be about
December 24th when Danny gets that scary
email from Terry who stops responding at
that point after getting the news about
the death of her family Danny calls
Christian and she can be heard wailing
over the phone
remember that sound Christian does his
best to be there for her but he's just
one person and he's already lost
interest in the relationship supporting
her through this tragedy is a big burden
on him Danny is given the rest of the
school year off in order to recover and
her and Christian stay together for
several more months although it's on
hold for now the writing is still on the
wall for the end of their relationship
literally in Danny's apartment there's a
painting of a girl in a crown kissing a
bear foreshadowing dany's eventual
crowning as the May Queen and
Christian's Fates being burned alive in
a bear costume there's also a painting
of these two moons which seems to be
connected to the lunar cycle and strange
passage of time as I mentioned earlier
another shows a woman running naked
through a forest we later see Christian
running naked after realizing he's
cheated on Dany both of these paintings
are shown in Winter the opposite of
Summer if you take the opposite of both
paintings you have two sons and a man
running naked which makes a lot more
sense for the movie maybe I'm over
speculating but it feels like there's
something there in the late spring we
see a picture on the door of dany's
apartment that kind of resembles Maya
the Swede that Christian would
eventually cheat on her with in June
2019 Danny is napping and wait except
just in time to go to a small party with
Christian and his friends she learns
that Pell has invited Josh to go to
Sweden to study their culture for his
thesis and Mark and Christian are going
as well Christian tries to make the
plans look less concrete than they
really are but the trip is in two weeks
and would last from mid-june to mid-july
when they get home she confronts him for
not telling her and she fake apologizes
realizing it's going to be a fight he
tries to leave but she begs him not to
she's trying way harder to make the
relationship work than he is because she
still needs her boyfriend as an
emotional crutch eventually his guilt
causes him to just invite Dany to Sweden
to make things less weird and she
surprises him by accepting the
invitation she goes over to Mark and
Josh's Apartments to talk about the trip
there you'll see a book on the table the
secret Nazi language of Uther and look
it's yellow the other theory is a theory
about deciphering runic alphabets it's
part of the purpose of Josh's travels to
Sweden learning about the runic alphabet
is a big part of his thesis paper The
Mention Of The Secret Nazi language is
interesting the word Nazi is short for
this really long German word that
translates to national socialism social
is the idea of collective ownership
rather than individual ownership if
you've heard of the Nazis you know that
their main goal was to see his power so
they're technically not socialist
they're just using that in their title
because it was a popular buzzword at the
time in Germany from what I understand
in essence the whole situation isn't
very different from how the horga elders
named Reuben as the Oracle but they were
still the ones to interpret his nothing
Burger painting So essentially they had
the power while making it look like
somebody else held the power unlike the
Nazis however the horga are full on
socialists usually socialism applies to
the economic model socialists might
collectively share land money businesses
Etc the horga have essentially expanded
this to all aspects of Life they
collectively share emotions relationship
Partners food and living arrangements
this is a politics free Channel I'm not
trying to sell you on any political
ideas I'm just trying to explain why
this book is here be script is a little
more overt about the Nazi comparison
Josh asks are the swedes sensitive about
their history of Nazi collaboration to
which Pell responds are you sensitive
about Hiroshima or slavery or the Trail
of Tears this could also protect
potentially be connected to how
Bloodlines are handled one of the
villagers mentions that the elders are
careful to preserve Bloodlines which was
one of the main goals of the Nazi party
to create a master race the cult in the
movie is almost exclusively made up of
people with pale skin light hair and
light eyes lo and behold the only
Outsider that they allow to survive is
Danny who fits right in with their
genealogical traits anyway as Pell
explains his homeland to Danny he's the
only one in the group that seems
genuinely warm towards her you know I'm
very very glad you're coming I think
it's very good you're coming he starts
to bring up how sorry he was to hear
that Dany lost her parents but she gets
choked up and has to leave to compose
herself in the bathroom it feels like he
has a thing for her and he probably does
but he doesn't get a chance to explain
why he's happy to have Dany specifically
joining them on the trip we'll get to
that after once again being overwhelmed
with sadness on the plane Danny and the
group land in Sweden and hit the road
towards housing land where Fear and
Loathing would await them
as Danny Christian Pell Josh and Mark
make their way to Pell's commune a sign
overhead can be translated to stop Mass
immigration to house England this is
their first clue that they're not as
welcome as they think they are as
tourists they take a rest stop where
they run into some organ people that
pelmos who are also coming home for
mid-summer one of which is his brother
ingamar this is not to say that pel and
ingomar necessarily have the same
parents but the cult is referred to as a
family as Cults so often do to avoid
suspicion so everyone your age is
considered a brother or sister and
Elders are considered mothers or fathers
ingomar also has two guests from the UK
Simon and Connie they're all going to
take some magic mushrooms together but
Danny wants to wait in order to get her
foot in Christian says that he'll wait
with her which upsets Mark who insists
that they need to take them at the same
time in order to experience the effect
simultaneously Artie Astor is drawing a
parallel here between the friend group
and the cult the cult experiences things
like joy and sorrow together
simultaneously notice how Mark doesn't
have jax until Christian says that he's
going to wait with Danny Mark doesn't
view Dany as part of their family
causing her to eventually feel more at
home as part of the Horgan family in
this case Danny doesn't want to get in
the way and so she offers to take the
mushrooms alongside the other later on
they're chilling on the hillside and
Mark gets hypersensitive when somebody
walks up to them I don't want new people
right now
no new people are good more of course
Pell would say that he literally needs
to bring new people into the cult in
order for their family to contend you
Danny just seems kind of spaced out in
days during all of this until she sees
grass growing on the back of her hand
texture's moving on trees warping
Landscapes and the sounds of nature
suddenly stopping
you're like my real actual family when
she hears Mark say that I think she's
pulled out of the moment and reminded
about the tragedy that befell her own
family and she seems to think she's
going to die in a panic she gets up and
says she's going for a walk eventually
ending up in an outhouse where she sees
the frightening image of her sister with
a gas hose plastered over her mouth this
freaks her out and she runs into the
woods and falls asleep dreaming about
her parents and sister the next thing
she knows they're waking her up
explaining that they found her in the
field six hours ago but Christian
doesn't wish her a happy birthday the
last part of the journey is on foots
before they come through the sun gate to
find a picturesque village where they're
greeted by flutist performing sweet folk
music Pell introduces them to his sister
dagne it feels significant that the
first person he chooses to introduce is
a sister with a similar name to Danny
almost like he's demonstrating that
someone like her could be a part of the
family Dany also attempts to respond to
her in Swedish ah attack a foreshadowing
of her eventual ability to apparently
communicate with the sisters in their
own language next Pell introduces father
odd who tells each of the boys welcome
but for Dany gives her a hug and says
Welcome Home music directs their
attention to a gathering under the giant
uh maypole where they toast to the
beginning of the festivity later that
day all the foreigners sit out on
blankets as the villagers dance around
Danny watches as one of the dancing
women Maya kicks her boyfriend in the
side he asked Pell if he can join in and
he and Josh run off Pell takes this
opportunity to give Danny a birthday
gift a portrait that he's drawn of her
he tells her it's just between them and
she has to awkwardly explain how Christy
and forgot that it was her birthday hell
is continuing to plant the seeds that
Dany will be treated better as a family
member of the horga than she is in a
relationship with Christian this seed
continues to grow later that day when
Connie asks how long they've been
together and Christian says that it's
been about three and a half years Danny
corrects him explaining that it's
actually been four years and two weeks
meaning that not only did he forget her
birthday but he also forgot their
anniversary Connie and Simon shared that
they're engaged and upon hearing that
word Dany overreacts with excitement
while Christian hardly seems to pay this
any mind more interested in the
triangle-shaped temple in the distance
which he's told that nobody is allowed
inside don't worry man you'll get your
chance subscribers of this channel
already know that this wasn't the first
time a triangle was associated with
secret cult activity and an ariaster
Fest as this was also something I
discussed when covering hereditary I
also noticed that Mark is using a vape
throughout the film to the horga he's an
outsider in hereditary Outsiders gather
around the house of the Graham family
and similarly we can see their breath
only in hereditary it is because of the
cold at the main House Pell explains the
system of different age ranges being
represented by seasons and when Dany
asks what happens after 72 he does a
Cutthroat motion she lasts thinking that
he's just joking completely unaware of
the ceremony that would take place the
next day but before Danny's birthday
celebration comes to a close Christian
finally remembers to wish her a happy
birthday unenthusiastically giving her a
cake as he struggles to light the candle
the scene represents how the flame
between them is dying and literally
between them in the shot we see five
women all nurturing a baby together as
one the shot visually demonstrates how
the appeal of always having a family to
care for you is coming between them and
their one-on-one romantic relationship
even if Danny doesn't realize what's
going on yet Christian weekly apologizes
for forgetting claiming he got confused
by the constant daylight that daylight
is blocked out at bedtime that evening
so they can get some sleep Danny sees a
pair of scissors placed under a baby's
pillow it seems unsafe and it is don't
try it I was able to find a possible
explanation for this some believe that
placing scissors under your pillow can
prevent bad dreams which would make
sense considering that they all sleep in
one room and would probably want to
avoid the baby crying in the middle of
the night however this Superstition
seems to only exist in Egypt or China
and I couldn't find anything linking it
to Sweden so I kept surging eventually I
came across this scene where Dany talks
to a woman cradling a baby that is not
her own she explains that part of the
reason that birth parents go away on
pilgrimage is that the time away helps
the babies detach allowing them to be
raised by the community this comment by
the witch 666 on Reddit suggests that
the scissors under the pillow May
symbolize The Cutting or detaching from
the parent just as you literally cut the
umbilical cord when the baby is ready to
survive on his or her own Pell hints
that there's a big ceremony the next day
and Danny's only clue is that it seems
to be getting a big reaction out of Josh
The Devout cultural anthropology
students however he refuses to Spill the
Beans in the night Dany awakes to the
sound of the crying baby and sees the
mural of a smiling man opening his wrist
with a knife while surrounded by smiling
friends even the sun is smiling down on
them this would be her first clue about
how this group feels about human
sacrifice they're proud of it and it's a
part of what the next day she takes
notice as the villagers perform some
kind of ritual which is described as a
dance class in the script the group
imitates the movements of the leader
which I see as practice for when they
need to share the burden of a family
member's emotions Danny picked some
flowers for Christian before that
morning's Feast which he picked while
walking backwards just like the horga
woman she is showing more and more signs
that she's assimilating into their
culture at this Meal special emphasis is
placed on these two Elders after eating
and Performing some strange chance there
led to the Cliffside where Dany and the
other Western hailing guests are in for
a serious
shock
[Music]
even before experiencing her first
attestable ritual Danny looks nervous
and uncomfortable it's as if she knows
that something is wrong much like how
she knew there was an issue after
receiving that email from her sister six
months prior Aster is drawing attention
to the similarities between the two
scenes there's even a character who
breaks the fourth wall just like Terry
did in Danny's dream when she sees the
first Elder jump she gasps and grabs
Christian's hand and her entire world
goes spin it when the male Elder jumps
he doesn't die but instead breaks his
leg at the base of the cliff so the
entire cult moans in agony alongside him
until four of them go over there and
finish the job with a giant hammer this
is Danny's first time seeing this
concept of group suffering and she would
eventually experience it for herself
Connie and Simon are especially offended
so SIV the family matriarch tries to
explain that the end of life is actually
a great joy in their culture review Life
as a circle a recycle then she makes
direct eye contact with Danny almost as
if she's trying to sell this lifestyle
to her
lashing back at a suitable
corrupts the spirit given that you just
spent the last half of a year in misery
and mourning this gives Danny a lot to
think about and she breaks off on her
own during the hike back Christian
leaves her alone to cry and she's so
distraught that she struggles to even
breathe when she comes back to the
commune she begins packing up to leave
but Pell shows up once again Danny
breaks down telling him she doesn't know
why she's here and Pell finally gets the
opportunity to explain why he was most
excited for her to come out of everyone
he tells her that he knows what she's
going through because he lost his
parents too in a fire when he was little
he's probably neglecting to mention that
this was a controlled fire another
ritual sacrifice but he's trying to show
her that their way of life may be better
for her I never got the chance to feel
lost because I had a family here where
everyone embraced me and swept me up
and I was raised by a community that
doesn't bicker over with stairs and
what's not theirs this refers to Josh
and Christian fighting over the
ownership of their thesis idea and
refusing to work together but I have
always felt held
by a family
a real family which everyone deserves
and you deserve he holds her hands and
she becomes worried that Christian could
walk in and to which he directly
challenges their relationship asking if
she feels held by him he's using their
dying relationships to try to recruit
her to the cult does she feel like home
to you when she does talk to Christian
about the sacrifices that they witnessed
that day he tells her that he's trying
to keep an open mind and acclimate not
realizing that he's actually encouraging
her to do exactly what Pell wants her to
do that night she borrows the sleeping
pill from Josh she has a nightmare where
she sees her friends leaving in the car
without her this is also where she
screams out black smoke and visualizes
her family dying at the bottom of the
cliff the pill causes her to sleep in so
she misses Josh discovering the love
room that Maya placed on Christian's bed
and Mark getting in trouble for pissing
on the sacred ancestral tree she's just
waking up as Connie storms in to pack
her bags clearly offended by the idea of
human sacrifice father odd comes up and
informs Connie that Simon went on to the
train station without her and that he'll
be sending the truck back to get her
which doesn't really make sense Danny is
understandably Disturbed by this and
later tells Tristan but he doesn't react
much which shows his lack of empathy
especially in comparison to Pal he goes
right back to interviewing one of the
villagers for his thesis Danny has this
moment where she looks like she's
realizing he isn't the guy she thinks he
is she wanders around outside the
kitchen and is invited to come in and
help in the scene Danny can be observed
taking in the scent of the small sachet
we saw pal offer this to her earlier
saying that it'll calm her down but she
refuses it as usual the script offers
more insights telling us that it
contains a special herb knowing what we
know now it can be assumed that this
herb is meant to have some kind of
effect such as opening her up to the
cult's influence she goes inside and
helps prepare meat Tarts but what kind
of means and Maya can be seen setting
one aside as she takes them out of the
oven she hears screaming in the distance
at supper Danny is concerned about
Connie who is now missing she questions
why Simon would leave without her and
tells Christian that she could see him
doing that the seating arrangement with
her between Christian and Pell mirrors
their sleeping Arrangement and
represents her growing internal conflict
which way will Danny Go Christian finds
a hair in his pie which Mark identifies
as a pubic hair somehow you'll also
notice that his drink is a slightly
different color than everyone else's
this all ties back to the so-called Love
Story a sort of comic on display in the
village where a girl mixes hair into a
guy's food and certain bodily fluids
into his drink to hypnotize him into
marrying and knocking her up this is
Maya's plan for Christian I'm guessing
she has never read Harry Potter and the
Half-Blood Prince Dany once again uses a
sleeping pill to snooze through the
events in the night when she wakes up
the first thing she sees is pel changing
surely this can be a coincidence at
breakfast one of the elders says that a
book from the temple is missing and
Christian and Danny are confronted about
their friends Josh and Mark who have
also gone missing in the night Christian
tells them that he doesn't associate as
friends or Associates of Josh if he
stole the book further explaining that
he'd be embarrassed to be connected to
this in any way how ironic that the one
supposedly studying this culture for his
college paper still doesn't understand
that everything is communal in the
culture there's no personal
responsibility in these people's minds
Danny is told to go with the women for
the day's activity and SIV wants to see
Christian in her house Christian seems
to accept this as if it's out of his
hands and it's an awkward moment for all
this is when the yellow tea is brewed
the women are dressed in Floral crowns
and Dany is given traditional clothing
the next step towards her integrating
into the cult they all join hands and
circle around the maypole and she gets
very uncomfortable and sees grass
growing out of her feet just like when
she took the mushrooms upon arriving in
Sweden as she's becoming more and more a
part of the horga family she's becoming
one with nature as the religion is
deeply tied to Nature and how they break
their lives in the seasons wear clothing
inspired by Nature Etc the rules are
explained and the horgolitan dance
begins not long into it Danny straight
up bodies some check
if you're looking for it Maya seems to
fall on purpose which would fit into the
plan of her hooking up with Christian as
the May Queen celebrations take place
speaking of whom Christian watches from
the sidelines when Dany makes the elite
eight she looks into the crowd and sees
everyone cheering besides her boyfriend
when the dancing starts again Oola Hands
Christian a drink
water with the
special properties she tells him it
breaks down your defenses and opens you
up for influence in that sense it really
is very similar to the herbs from
hereditary the difference being instead
of Supernatural influence it's
psychoactive influence I think a lot of
people are quick to shout Cinematic
Universe when it comes to ariaster but
if you think about it nothing in
mid-summer merits the existence of the
supernatural or any higher power even
when Dany somehow begins speaking
Swedish with the other contestants it
suggested that this is just a
hallucination and they're actually
communicating through dance in fact in
the script they're actually just
speaking complete gibberish the last two
Swedish girls Glide and fall down so
Dany is declared the winner but it
wouldn't be long before the celebration
would be cut short with crippling grief
Dany is crowned as the May Queen which
comes as a complete surprise to her the
celebration began father odd repeatedly
tells her welcome and Maya touches
foreheads with her this shows that Dany
is being accepted into the cult by doing
what they do she is one of them however
she's still feeling the effects of the
mind-altering beverage ingomar's eyes
look huge then she sees what appears to
be her father with completely mismatched
eyes and her mother passing through the
crowd Pell kisses her on the lips now
that she's been recruited to the cult
it's not weird because of how the family
all shares their love for each other
there's no concept of belonging to a
specific person as Dany is lifted onto
the pedestal I'm fairly certain that's
Terry standing to her right through all
of this Christian just watches in the
distance totally spaced out at one point
Pell had asked her if she felt held by
Christian and now she's literally being
held up by her new family there's some
kind of meat being served at the feast
possibly their friends who were taken
out the previous night the meat has
flies buzzing around it one last time
I've got to mention however reminded of
hereditary where the body riding in the
Attic attracts an insane amount of flaw
from overhead one of the platters looks
like a woman which is fitting
considering what's about to take place
the May Queen is going to bless the
crops in livestock and Christian is
going to impregnate Maya both are tied
to the idea of fertility the table which
has been rearranged to take the shape of
various runes throughout dany's time in
Sweden is now one straight long line
maybe for similar reasons to the shape
of the maypole Dany attempts to eat the
lucky Herring but doesn't get far and
everyone laughs it seems fitting that
she rejects the fish a fish is often
used as a symbol to represent
Christianity the religion dany's
soon-to-be ex-boyfriend is named
Christian and she's literally moving
from him to a Pagan religion dagne the
first sister that Pell introduced at the
beginning is also the first one to call
Danny a sister
yeah
you are the family now yes yes
Pell also makes a drawing of Dany as the
May Queen previously he stated that
drawing portraits is something that he
does for birthday this signifies how
she's been reborn into her new family
just as the family views life as
cyclical relationships also operate in a
cycle Danny's relationship has been
dying for some time but like an elder in
a nursing home this relationship's best
years are already gone the horga say
goodbye to their Elders before that can
happen and they do the same to Dany and
Christian's relationship a chariot comes
to take Dany to perform the blessings
and she asks if Christiane can come with
her to which sieve informs her
the queen must Ride Along when they said
off the carriage is pulled by only women
and while she's gone Christian is lured
into the temple where he finally
succumbs to Maya's plot along with
several other women it wouldn't be an
a24 film without a bunch of creepy naked
people would it when Dany returns from
The Chariot trip she's told to go to
siv's house for a special meeting for
the May Queens but notices that
something is going on at the temple
what's that
that's not for us she ignores this
advice and goes there anyways looking
distraught almost as if she already
knows what's going on inside this is the
third time we've seen her freak out
before a tragedy which serves to connect
this with the death of her parents and
her witnessing the attestable she looks
into the keyhole and confirms her
suspicions but this time unlike the
previous two she does not have Christian
to dump her emotional baggage onto
instead her new family is there for her
and they all share the burden of her
heartbreak together the sound of her
wailing is just like what we heard after
she found out that her family died but
this time it is echoed by everyone
[Music]
oh
where Christian couldn't muster enough
emotion to mourn with her when dany's
parents and sister passed away the cult
makes her feel connected and held the
entire scenario says something about
Colts in general the members are often
people struggling with a sense of
belonging and that need to belong clouds
their better judgment after Christiane
realizes what he's done he runs out to
find the remains of his friends before
being captured and sedated when he
awakes Dany stands upon a stage having
been completely covered in flowers but
still looking sad this is representative
of the love bombing techniques that
Colts have been known to use to draw new
followers the final ceremony is to
involve the sacrifice of nine human
bodies four new Bloods which are Simon
Connie Mark and Josh and for horga the
pair of 72 year old elders and two new
volunteers the ninth and final sacrifice
is set to be decided by the May Queen
either a randomly selected Horgan or her
at this point probably ex-boyfriend
Christian the Horgan selection is some
guy named tubion who we've literally
never heard of or seen before this just
goes to show how Danny's character Arc
is now complete she no longer needs
Christian whatsoever and she chooses him
to be placed inside a bear carcass and
burned alive inside of the Triangular
Temple since the two cult members who
volunteered to burn were still alive the
entire cult emotes their suffering with
them as the place burns down and Dany
joins her new family in the agony the
burning Temple symbolizes the purging of
her old life and old relationship she is
being a reborn her trauma is being left
in the past life and once this
realization hits her all she can do is
smile
foreign
[Music]
and Midsummer is a catharsis for Ari
Astor who has been open about the film
being event for a breakup he was going
through at the time a breakup can be
cataclysmic and turn your life upside
down and almost feel like a dad I wanted
to make a big operatic breakup movie
that felt and played as consequential as
the end of a relationship feels to the
parties involved as devastating as that
can be this doesn't have to be the end
of our relationship because you can
check out my analysis on kingpayman from
hereditary on the left and you can
subscribe to cz's world for new Horrors
every week ring the death bell for
notifications yep just like that and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive